[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
ich habe mir gedacht das wird mal wieder
Zeit für einen leckeren Kuchen heute
gibt es einen Apfel crumble Cheesecake
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dafür braucht ihr auch eine ganz wenige
Zutaten wir machen eine krabbelmasse
eine Cheesecake Masse und machen
Bratäpfel fertig ich zeige euch mal die
Zutaten für den Chromebook ich nehme
dafür 200g Butter die darf gerne kalt
sein 200g Zucker etwas Salz 400 g Mehl
ihr könnt Weizen oder Dinkel verwenden
und zwei Teelöffel Zimt jetzt kommen
alle Zutaten hier in die Rührschüssel
ihr könnt sie gerne mit den Händen
verkneten ihr könnt einen Teigs Messer
nehmen ihr könnt ein Handrührgerät mit
Knethaken nehmen oder nimmt eine
Küchenmaschine und den Flachrührer das
Butterstück hier will einfach nicht rein
aber
[Musik]
aus weiter geht's
sind die Streusel fertig und die sehen
jetzt so ein bisschen bröselig aus aber
wenn ihr sie jetzt so zusammendrückt
sieht man schon dann halten sie so sind
Streusel perfekt das heißt ich drücke
dir jetzt ein bisschen zusammen stellt
in den Kühlschrank und kann schon mal
die Bratäpfel zubereiten ich habe jetzt
dafür hier ein paar Äpfel das sind 400
Gramm in steinte bzw entkernte Äpfel
etwas Zucker 50 Gramm es kommt hier
schon mal in meine Pfanne und bei den
Äpfeln achtet ihr einfach drauf dass es
so säuerliche Äpfel sind ihr könnt Äpfel
nehmen die super zum Backen sind da
Boskop passt alles perfekt den Zucker
lasse ich jetzt in der Pfanne kurz
karamellisieren und die Äpfel habe ich
einfach so in Spalten geschnitten
und sobald der Zucker hier jetzt
karamellisiert ist kommen die Äpfel dazu
die bratet jetzt einfach drei vier fünf
Minuten mit an bis sie einfach schön
Farbe haben
[Musik]
das ganze wird dann nur noch mit etwas
Zitronensaft abgeschmeckt und dann ist
die Apfelfüllung fertig
jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit der
Cheesecake Masse dafür nehme ich 425
Gramm Frischkäse 250 g Quark 150 Gramm
Puderzucker 60g Stärke 3 Eier etwas
Vanilleextrakt und etwas Abrieb und Saft
einer Zitrone hier gebt ihr jetzt alle
Zutaten rein am besten immer erst
Frischkäse Quark Puderzucker Stärke
schön cremig verrühren und dann die Eier
und den Rest dazu geben damit keine
Klümpchen entstehen
[Musik]
tatsächlich nicht so viel
soll er kein Zitrone werden und bisschen
Zitronensaft
und die ausgedrückte Zitrone die
ausgedrückte Zitrone gebe ich immer in
die Spülmaschine als Spülmaschine Deo
ich nehme nur die Kerne voll raus dass
die den Filter nicht verstopfen und dann
ist es das Beste und natürlich das
Spülmaschine Deo was ihr nehmen könnt
außerdem ist Zitronensaft auch gegen
Kalk deswegen auch sehr gut
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier die drei
Bestandteile crumble Cheesecake und die
Äpfel und habe jetzt hier eine Backform
die habe ich auf 25 cm Durchmesser
eingestellt es wird ein schöner dicker
cremiger Cheesecake ihr könnt das ganze
aber auch gerne mit nur einer Schicht
machen auch gerne auf einem Blech backen
ganz wie ihr möchtet falls ihr die Größe
verändern wollt die Menge verändern
wollt könnt ihr immer in meiner App
vorbeischauen da könnt ihr nämlich von
rund auf eckig aufgrund von Groß offline
von klein auf groß alles mögliche
umrechnen und das macht wirklich die App
automatisch jetzt gebe ich etwa die
Hälfte der Streusel in die Form
so ungefähr
dann drückt ihr da jetzt einen Rand und
auch den Boden fest
am Boden am besten im Glas oder auch mit
einem Messbecher flachdrücken oder zum
Beispiel die burgerpresse nehmen
dann kommt jetzt die Hälfte der Masse
rein
schön verteilen
dann die Hälfte der Äpfel drüber
verteilen
das riecht jetzt schon richtig gut
[Musik]
jetzt auch die Hälfte der Streusel noch
drüber geben
und dann kommt zum Schluss noch mal
Cheesecake drauf restliche Streusel
restliche Äpfel und ab in den Backofen
und so hat man nämlich den crumble am
Boden in der Mitte und obendrauf
wird ein Kuchen der wird uns alle
umhauen
[Musik]
und so kommt der Kuchen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten Backofen bei 170 Grad ober
Unterhitze der braucht schon eine Weile
also die Zubereitung ist wirklich
einfach beim Backen brauche etwas länger
als eine Stunde und dann darf er
natürlich abkühlen und wir werden ihn
dann gemeinsam probieren ich freue mich
jetzt schon
richtig gut falls übrigens ein
backsensor in eurem Bosch Backofen habt
könnt ihr auch einfach mit backsensor
packen dann müsst ihr nämlich nicht mehr
auf die Backzeit achten da macht es der
Ofen von ganz alleine und falls ihr den
Ofen habt und meine App habt dann könnt
ihr auch direkt die Einstellwerte aus
der App an den Backofen senden
[Musik]
the party freut sich endlich wird mal
hier wieder gebacken
[Musik]
die Worte großkleiden
also die großmütze mal
also uns schmeckt der Kuchen richtig gut
probieren gerne aus ihr findet das
Rezept in der App kostenlos runterladen
und dann backt den gerne nach wünscht
euch gerne Rezepte wir sehen uns wieder
beim nächsten Mal wenn ihr uns einladen
wollt
die kuchentester Kuchenbäcker
[Musik]
okay ich nehme dann den Teller tschüss